you have been an early investor 200
million plus dollars
95 is a big point bitcoin had crashed
from 20 000 to 7000. i think this thing
is going to hit three before it goes
back to 10.
at that point it took about 50 of my net
worth put it into bitcoin legacy system
versus this new system all of the assets
that you could invest in
bitcoin is going to outperform i've got
such deep conviction here i've really
been studying this for years sitting
here now today i look like a genius but
frankly it was scary you predicted 2026
bitcoin's gonna get to a million because
an event that's going to take place in
i personally believe that one day
bitcoin will be a
hundred trillion dollar asset to a lot
of people saying bitcoin's the safest
place to put your money
how can you save bitcoins the safest
place it has the best cyber defense
you cannot hack bitcoin i can actually
go look on chain i can see every single
wallet who's selling who's buying
buffet is talking about silver he's
sitting on 200 billion dollars of cash
but buffett is not bottom when you look
at a warren buffett he hasn't
outperformed the s
p for the last decade if you had taken
his approach you've underperformed
people have spoken this is superior
technology it's a better system they
want it and they're gonna use it
[Music]
so just last week on twitter i posed a
question i said look i would like to
have a symposium of crypto experts
from opposing sides meaning if in
politics we have the democrats and
republicans
give me both sides of cryptos some are
ethereum some are bitcoin some are
whatever
i want to do a symposium and you know
bring him here to valuetainment florida
let's have a debate and let's have a
good conversation everybody can watch it
live
the number one requested name was my
guest today
anthony pomp pompliano who's a former
veteran
who was in iraq he served and he came
out all of a sudden he decided to get
into the financial industry spent
thousands of hours studying
the concepts of finance and now when the
topic of bitcoin comes up
people contact this guy anthony with
that being said thank you so much for
being a guest on the entertainment
absolutely thanks so much for having me
yes so so so
walk me through how you go from being a
vet
in the u.s army to all of a sudden
getting into crypto how did that take
place
yeah i mean the short story is uh when i
got out of the military
uh i came back from iraq i went back to
school and finished it was
really important uh from my father's
perspective i was the first person in my
family to graduate from college
uh and so i was kind of a big thing in
his mind and uh you know in hindsight
was a great decision
uh then i started a couple of businesses
and frankly i knew nothing about
starting businesses made every mistake i
could write a book about everything not
to do
but ended up being all right and
eventually went and worked at facebook
ran some product and growth teams there
and then started investing
in early stage technology once i left
facebook
and the key piece to investing is just
somebody told me early on follow the
talent right if smart people are all
going to work on something
go start paying attention go start
learning about it and uh it just became
very clear that there was a ton of
intellectual capital flowing towards
uh cryptocurrency in the entire industry
and so i got my start actually building
mining facilities
uh actually using the computational
power to uh to mine bitcoin or ether
uh and then kind of fed on the rabbit
hole and now i'm sitting here talking to
you
now let me ask you the first time you
invested into crypto or bitcoin what
year was the first time you put a dollar
what year was it so the literally the
very first cryptocurrency ever got
uh was actually ether and uh i didn't
convert
dollars i bought some mining machines
and uh and mined them
i think it was just like uh end of 2016
which at the time
i was like frantic uh because i thought
i was so late i missed the whole thing
and uh you know talked to people from
2012 and they said well when i got in i
thought i had missed the whole
thing and you talked to the people today
and they said they think they missed the
whole thing and so
uh 2016 was the first time but uh but
it's pretty uh pretty cool to see how
far the industry's grown since then
so 20 you know i spoke to metta kovan i
think you had him on a couple days ago
as well
he also got in like 2014 2015-2016 it's
not like he's been around he
he got into it also recently and then
boom you know some call him a
crypto billionaire he's the guy that bob
beeples every days i think for 69.3
million but
going back to facebook what happened
with the facebook snap thing i read
something on
some challenges happen with facebook
snap you call them out you know hey your
numbers are
what happened there what was that issue
about yeah look you know
it's uh uh businesses business right and
so uh when i was at facebook we we built
a number of really really great products
uh i was we
first was working on the grow team for
facebook pages uh
and we were basically helping small
medium-sized businesses use the platform
uh and then before i left i had the
great opportunity to uh to help on some
products that
many people use today so uh one is the
amber alert product where basically when
a kid in that child uh
um you know the alert goes out basically
in your news feed you'll get a
notification saying hey you know be on
the lookout call number
uh and then voter registration um and
voter registration was
um uh really interesting because uh
facebook doesn't care which side you
vote right with that product they just
want more people registered to vote
uh and so when we launched it from
america i think it was in the uk
uh it was responsible for like a
double-digit percentage of voter
registration
uh it's just cool to see kind of these
platforms and just how much reach they
have and their ability to uh
really drive uh folks to uh to kind of
you know do things that are good for
society got it and then uh
so so amber alert and voter registration
while you were at facebook
when you were at facebook did you work
directly with mark or no were you
were you working with them i'm curious
yeah so um
for a very short period of time about uh
i don't know six weeks eight weeks uh
there was a team put together
uh that really tried to help uh both
mark zuckerberg and sheryl sandberg
uh just better understand the platform
what was happening on their pages
you gotta remember that uh in the
dominant platforms before
around social uh how does the founder of
the platform
interact with people on the platform so
tom from myspace everyone remembers he
friended everybody
right so everyone was tom's friend and
it kind of became this like cultural
meme
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
uh facebook didn't do that um but
really how do you as the founder of the
platform how do you talk to people and
and so there was a team put together
that basically tried to understand that
um it was part of a larger effort just
around measuring sentiment on facebook
and things like that and so
uh that was really my only experience
working with uh with mark or cheryl
um and frankly i was blown away i had
the opportunity as a young kid to uh to
sit some meetings with them and
to watch uh you know a multi-billionaire
who's built this amazing business that
you know was one of the most valuable
technology companies in the world
literally in a meeting go from talking
about the individual um
kind of strategy of a team or a product
all the way down to in the middle of a
presentation start talking about the
pixels and the design
and then go back to kind of the macro
level um you know strategy stuff
it's just it's absolutely incredible to
watch uh in real time
what was cheryl's strength if that was
his he can go technical and he can go
more you know general
what was cheryl's strength i think she's
just a great operator right she really
really understands how to operate a
business she understood a lot of the
revenue right all the things that i
think people from the external say like
oh this is what she is there to do
uh she's done a fantastic job with and
it's very obvious why when you
get to sit and talk and listen to her
talk um but the other piece of this too
i think is somebody once told me they
were like look
uh both of them have the advantage of
they've got more context than most of
the people in the meeting
right zuck's the longest standing
employee at facebook and so he was
literally there when a lot of these
design or product decisions were made
the people who else were in the room
most of them have moved on
right and so when you're talking to mark
you can have all the ideas in the world
he literally just has an information
advantage right he's been around he
knows why certain decisions were made
and so naturally what you want to do is
you want to just kind of learn from
those people and so
i was like 25 maybe 26 years old uh when
i got the opportunity to
work alongside not only them but also a
number of the the people who saw
facebook and leadership positions
and i just try to soak it up you know
it's just like surround yourself with
people who uh
who are smarter than you more
experienced and frankly just shut up and
listen
and that was kind of my strategy well it
looks like it worked
so the question for you would be when is
the first time you made money well you
would say pat i
made money my first big success of money
was
i exited this place i had this many
shares company went public
i bought this i flipped this what was
your first big victory you had with
money
yeah so the first time i made real money
and i say real money because
a lot of the the companies that i built
and sold and all this stuff uh there was
earn outs there was kind of paper gains
there's all this stuff but but not
actual real money right
and you kind of learn those lessons
again like i said i made every mistake
in the book
uh but when i left uh facebook i had
some uh stock and uh the stock had
appreciated
uh i think like 300 or something uh
while i was there
and so uh in 2016 i think it was
uh is when i actually sold the shares uh
and i basically took 50
of it i put in the bank and said okay
you know i'm gonna have this money and
i'll be able to live off of it for a
while
and the other 50 i took and i went and i
uh basically put it into cryptocurrency
mining
and so i've always been somebody who
believes in kind of concentration
uh and kind of not taking a ton of shots
but when you take a shot you know and
you make sure you know what you're
talking about you got an advantage uh go
in
and try to exploit it and that's what i
uh kind of really made money for the
first time
dramatically against what traditional
you know
rhetoric we keep hearing about is don't
have your money concentrated in one
specific area what if you lose the whole
thing
you which i'm a proponent of you went
the complete opposite side
with uh putting all your money in one
place what do you think about that
well i think it depends on who you ask
right if you talk to let's say
a kind of a personal finance uh guru or
you talk to a financial advisor
really what they're optimizing for is
they're trying to optimize for
protecting the capital right they're not
necessarily optimizing for growing
capital a lot of protecting capitals a
lot of career risk involved there's not
their money in many cases
uh and so they're always talking about
diversification diversification is a
fantastic way to protect capital
but if you're trying to compound capital
and grow capital
diversification actually can be uh
detrimental it can be an obstacle to
that goal
and so when you look at you know a
warren buffett right he's famous for
saying
look diversification is for people who
don't know what they're doing
now maybe that's a little bit of a
hyperbole type statement he was trying
to make a point
but i do think that when you look at the
people who have built real wealth in the
world
almost all of them did it through
concentration they had a concentration
either in investments
or in the ownership of businesses that
they were running and so
naturally there's uh kind of not a black
and white world right if you want to
build wealth you got to have
concentration but once you get wealth
you better be smart enough to protect it
and that's where you can start to get
some diversification
uh to really make sure that you don't
lose it uh very true and the flip side
the opposite
you know opposing side will say well you
don't know a lot of people that also
went concentrate and lost everything
they had yes but if you're trying to get
for
get all the marbles you have to take
some risk which is what
we subscribe to so you have been an
early investor 20 200 million plus
dollars
in early early-stage companies and
including many different unicorns from
what i've been seeing lately
is it used to say 50 of your net worth
is in bitcoin i saw recently you said 95
is in bitcoin are you really 95 of
bitcoin today
yeah so uh in 2018 um i i made a ton of
mistakes between 2016 and 2018 when it
came to cryptocurrencies and i always
say that
uh people just have to go through the
learning like you have to go and
actually experience this stuff and so
everything from i tried to trade
realized i wasn't a good trader
to i started trying to mine different
things realized that wasn't a smart idea
uh and eventually in uh 2018 started to
really wrap my head around like what is
this thing
and so uh in august of 2018 i wrote a
thing publicly and i said hey we were
sitting around seven thousand dollars
bitcoin had crashed from twenty thousand
to seven thousand uh and i said look you
know based on everything that i've done
everything i've talked to
everything i've learned i think this
thing's gonna hit three before it goes
back to ten
and so i just sat there i waited it
eventually did that
and at that point it took about 50 of my
net worth put it into bitcoin
uh and i felt like 50 was the right
number mainly because it was
5050 legacy system versus this new
system i want to be equally split i'm a
young guy i've got good you know kind of
high earning potential
so i can take the concentrated risk if i
lose 50 percent it's not going to be the
end of the world it'll suck i won't be
happy but you know i can recover from
that
well fast forward to 2020 when all of
the kind of craziness started to happen
with the
economic uh uncertainty and then
obviously the government intervention
and kind of manipulation of markets
and this became very evident like look
if all of the assets that you could
invest in
bitcoin is going to outperform it is
going to serve as kind of that fastest
horse in the inflation hedge bucket as
paul tudor jones called it later in the
year and so i basically just said i'm
going all in
right i've got such deep conviction here
i've really been studying this for years
i've got a belief that this is going to
uh be the safest place for me to put my
wealth and so uh
going from what had been 50 to basically
all of my liquid cash other than what i
thought was
uh you know enough to live on uh i just
went all in bought bitcoin and
uh you know sitting here now today i
look like a genius but frankly it was
scary right
you uh you kind of buy making these buy
purchases and
you're just like i hope this works out
because if not i'm the biggest idiot in
the room
oh my gosh well i mean it worked in your
favor in a big way which is great and
today we're
i think today right now as of right now
bitcoin's at sixty one thousand four
fourteen i think it's at sixty one
thousand four fourteen
and uh to see you go from three k to
sixty one thousand two fourteen that's
20 x and that was fifty percent then you
go ninety five percent
so the question if 95 is bitcoin what's
yeah so uh the rest is and i should be
clear that uh
i think of that as kind of like my
liquid net worth right i've got a ton of
exposure to
uh illiquid companies i basically when i
think of kind of my portfolio i just
write all of that to zero
right i just say hey look uh some of
it'll become true some of it'll go to
zero like we'll see kind of what happens
there
um i'm very fortunate to have invested a
number of these great companies
uh that um you know from an illiquid
standpoint i don't know what the
valuation of all that is i just
you know kind of zero it out the only
other things that i have from an asset
perspective
are i own a little bit of real estate
and then it's cash so
i literally own no public stocks uh i've
got gbtc in a retirement account it's
the only public equity that i hold uh
and other than that then it's pretty
much just bitcoin
and so that's you know the belief is
that it's the savings technology that
has the best ability to
uh protect your purchasing power and
outperform those financial assets
uh so i choose just to have
concentration there you said
safest place now you have to realize to
a lot of people saying bitcoin's the
safest place to put your money i mean
you're driving many people insane to say
the safest place right
you know you save an account you got the
treasury bills you got
gold you got a investment company act of
america with american functions
1934 it's giving you 12.7 you got all
these other places
how can you save bitcoins the safest
place
so i'm going to give you two separate
frameworks that i use to think through
this right let's talk structurally first
so if i said to most people what's the
safest place to park your wealth they'll
say the us dollar
and that's true both in the western
world and also developing nations around
the world
there's this idea of stability safety
discipline in monetary policy like
all the things that we assign to the us
dollar and frankly
things that actually drive value in that
u.s dollar right kind of it being the
global reserve currency etc
but when you actually unpack that
structure what you find is the us
dollar's monetary policy the decisions
that
drive the value of it uh are not very
transparent there's a group of people
that go in a room privately
they make decisions we don't really have
a lot of understanding of exactly what
data they're looking at
why they're making decisions when they
make the announcements we hang on every
single word
do they use dovish or not right what
literally what color tie
are they wearing or not right i mean
it's just pretty pretty archaic type
um idea and then on top of that we get
no
say either so when they decided to do
two emergency rate cuts to the interest
rate in uh
uh q1 and q2 of 2020 all of a sudden
i had no say you had no say right then
when you look at all the quantitative
easing that's occurred
i had no say you had no say and so in
many cases
especially with the the central banking
these are not elected officials these
are appointed officials and so again
it's not something where it's the
uh kind of desires of the people now yes
they are appointed by people that were
elected so there's kind of an
indirectness to it but i think that
when you look at it's just not a
transparent system it's a very human
driven system
when you look at bitcoin it's the exact
opposite right and the reason why that's
important is because we've moved from
this narrative-based world which is this
old legacy world
around central banking and all financial
assets to now we're in a world where
i don't believe you prove it and so
if i ask people right now how many
dollars are in circulation
there's nobody who can tell you the
exact figure right if i say to you how
many
dollars were printed today or taken out
of circulation nobody can tell you
and so that is a narrative driven world
we're told that there's something there
and we kind of directionally
understand but we don't actually have
the provability when i look at something
like bitcoin it's a fully transparent
system so not only can i tell you how
many total bitcoin there will be in the
world
i can tell you exactly how many are in
circulation today i can tell you exactly
how many came into circulation
on this day exactly 900 bitcoin were
created today put into circulation
i can go back and i can actually show
you every single transaction that has
occurred since january 3rd 2009
and then on top of that and a really
important part is the monetary policy is
programmatic
meaning that i can actually tell you the
interest rate or inflation decisions
that are going to be made well into the
future literally decades into the future
because it's written in transparent code
and if that code ever changes we'll know
well in advance
and so now all of a sudden i say okay i
can choose to put my money into a fiat
currency
where i don't know the people who are
making the decision i don't know what
decisions they're going to make
and also they can do absolutely insane
things like
manipulate interest rates on emergency
schedules and
they printed 40 of all us dollars in
circulation the last 12 months
that's crazy because bitcoin bitcoin
just does what bitcoin does right we
know
every day for four years is going to
produce 900 bitcoin per day put it into
circulation
and then the beauty of it is you can
look on chain at all of the data
so if you even go to something like
stocks for example again from a
structural standpoint
coinbase recently went public and when
coinbase went public i think everyone
thought the stock was just going to take
off and
you know go to the moon well it didn't
really do that and so my
initial inclination was well maybe this
is like insiders because there's a
direct listing
uh there's no lock up here maybe there's
just insiders kind of you know capturing
their
profits and selling their cell pressure
and eventually it'll recover
but i can't go validate that in bitcoin
and crypto i can actually go look on
chain i can see every single wallet
who's selling who's buying
who's been holding how long have they
been holding when did they get that
bitcoin all that kind of stuff
and so it's just a more transparent
system and so when i think of safety
from a structural standpoint i want to
understand as much of the system as i
possibly can
then you've got to look at okay forget
my opinion forget anybody else's opinion
what's just the financial performance
and in a
year you know plus called 12 to 15
months where literally there couldn't
have been more economic chaos
uncertainty
bitcoin is by far the best performing
asset right if you look at the stock
markets up about 50 percent
gold is basically flat uh and bitcoin's
up 800 the last 12 months
it outperformed everything and the
reason why it did that
is because it's a supply and demand game
fixed supply
there was an awakening in the
institutional world that this
asset is going to serve as a store of
value for a long period of time
and you had a bunch of institutions
showing up trying to buy billions and
billions of dollars of bitcoin
but the bitcoiners aren't selling sixty
percent of bitcoin hasn't moved in the
last twelve months
and so sixty percent sixty percent
hasn't moved in the last twelve months
this is the most important thing for
people to understand from a market
structure standpoint
so 18.6 million bitcoin are in
circulation but 60
of that has not moved in the last 12
months and on top of that
the bitcoin that is available on the
exchanges
continues to drop so actually what
you're having is more as more people are
buying it they're pulling it into cold
storage
and they're long-term holders so really
the kind of addressable circulating
supply
is only 40 of that 18.6 million bitcoin
so now when these institutions show up
with billions of dollars there's
there's not a lot of bitcoin to buy
right and that's where you get this
rapid price appreciation that we've seen
over the last 12 months
so so let me ask you this there's only a
certain supply of bitcoin i can get
right you got 18.6 million
60 no one selling 40 people are selling
so 40
of 18.6 money due to math say eight and
a half say
nine million whatever the numbers okay
uh seven and a half million whatever the
numbers right okay
so how come if we only have a
limited amount of gold how come gold
didn't go up the same
level that bitcoin did during the same
exact period which means you can't go
print gold you can't go print uh bitcoin
why didn't gold go up the way crypto did
that bitcoin did so i think i think
there's two components to this
one is uh the statement there's a
limited supply of gold
we don't know that again a narrative
driven world we're told that gold is
scarce
but if i ask somebody well how much gold
is there right now in the circulating
supply again we don't know for a fact
right there's good guesses right so i
don't want to kind of uh take the uh
the extreme view of like nobody knows we
have
we have an educated guess but we don't
know with 100
certainty compared to like let's say a
bitcoin the second thing
is that gold from a a social consensus
standpoint ask anyone under the age of
35 if they're buying gold or bitcoin
right so what you have is you have a
capital shift from older kind of the
boomer generation
down to the younger generation but the
younger generation doesn't want to hold
gold
and so if you go and you look at the
same time that bitcoin went up uh
over the last like let's say six seven
months five hundred percent
gold is down pretty materially right
it's down like fifteen twenty percent
and so it's not what's that that doesn't
make any sense mathematically
well because people are selling it right
people are dropping gold and they're
buying bitcoin now again
it is unclear how much of the people
that are dropping gold and kind of
selling gold are actually going directly
to buy bitcoin
but what you can see is you can see an
inverse relationship as
gold has gone down bitcoin has gone up
and so what i think becomes
really really interesting is again a
store of value
ends up being more of a social consensus
than a
technology consensus right and what i
mean by that
is bitcoin is by far 10 100 maybe a
thousand x improvement on gold from a
technology standpoint it's more portable
it's more divisible right it's more
transparent verifiable all that kind of
stuff
so from a pure just technology
standpoint it is drastically more
superior
but actually what's more important is
the social consensus
if everyone was yelling and screaming
and saying go buy gold right during this
uh kind of economic chaos
gold would have went up right but
instead what does everyone have to talk
about what is cnbc talking about all day
long right what is the
uh institutional investment uh investors
all talking about bitcoin
and so naturally that's where capital
flows when capital flows to a fixed
supply asset price has to go up to
accommodate everybody
and so i think that you're just seeing a
generational shift here where
analog assets are going to get replaced
by digital assets and what history has
shown us
is that digital assets are always bigger
than their analog predecessors
because the internet is just so much
bigger than we ever give it credit for
so so let me ask you so when you look at
real estate you can say well if the
interest rate goes up you know
price of real estate goes down if real
estate you know rates go down
price of real estate goes up like kind
of right now the rates are kind of like
coming up a little bit and you're
noticing the prices dropping people like
hey
you know i thought i was going to pay
you know a seller for the price i want
to know rates went up a little bit right
so you can kind of directly correlate
rates to real estate
and many other things you can link to
real estate like when you think about
stock market
there's a bubble you know we have a bull
market bear market
war you know certain things that happens
okay i'm going to take my money out of
crisis that takes place
what is the direct correlation of
an event taking place to cause bitcoin
to go down
or up i think we know what up is but
what is down is what i'm curious about
yeah so uh from a macro view if you just
take a relative comparison between
bitcoin and all of these other assets
there are times just like in any asset
or market where there is higher degrees
of correlation
right so if you think of march of 2020
every asset sold off everyone wants
dollars
it's a liquidity crisis and so naturally
correlations go towards one
but when you look over a long period of
time over many years bitcoin's
correlation to most of the major
asset classes is about 0.15 so it's
heavily non-correlated to
other assets stocks bonds gold etc now
that doesn't mean that those short-term
periods don't lead to correlation right
so it's important to kind of long-term
short-term comparison
now when you look at things like
event-driven
price uh kind of um uh events
what you have to look at is why do
people value
bitcoin right it's actually usually
economic hedge or chaos head
schmuck insurance whatever you want to
call it or they look at it as some sort
of savings technology
or they look at it as speculation so to
your point when interest rates go down
and
kind of free money floods the system
people go speculate
and they're speculating in everything
from gamestop to bitcoin to name your
you know financial asset for that young
people are excited about
that is some portion of the population
but again 60
haven't sold or moved their bitcoin in
the last 12 months so those guys aren't
speculating those are long-term
believers holders whatever you want to
call them
so why are they holding this there's a
very big portion of it they just simply
look at it as a savings technology
if you look at most financial assets and
you denominate them in gold
and not dollars they're actually down
since 1971.
so the u.s stock market is down in gold
versus uh being up in
uh dollars why is that some will argue
right that
it's simply just the dollar being
devalued and so naturally you get kind
of
uh price appreciation of an asset that's
denominated in dollars because dollars
being devalued
well against bitcoin bitcoin actually is
increasing your purchasing power it's
not decreasing like the dollar is and so
those people just want to save in an
asset that will continue to appreciate
that
uh purchasing power rather than have it
decrease in dollars
and then the third bucket which is
actually a really really interesting
bucket is this smok
insurance right and so i think that
there's this very interesting kind of
conversation around
in the united states if you look at the
federal reserve's comments or you look
at other people
there's this belief that like we're
above it right it's american
exceptionalism that we that there's no
way that the dollar could ever fail
we'll never lose control from a monetary
policy standpoint
again i'm a believer of like it's a very
very low probability but it's a non-zero
probability
and so when you see things like you know
last year we heard a lot from the
federal reserve of we're not worried
about inflation inflation isn't going to
happen it's a deflationary environment
it can soak it up
all that kind of stuff well over the
last 60 days actually we started to see
some inflation
and now what we're being told is like oh
it's temporary and maybe it is maybe
it's not i don't know but like that's a
very different story than we were just
being told six nine months ago
and so when you look around the world
what you realize is there's a lot of
countries
that went from we're not worried about
inflation to inflation is temporary to
all of a sudden we can't control the
inflation
right and so like it doesn't take a lot
to spiral out of control
if anyone in the world is well equipped
to deal with it the united states is
probably that country right in terms of
we've been really
disciplined with monetary policy for a
long time we've got a lot of tools
we've got global reserve currency all
that but i do think that there is
a mispricing of risk in the market
where if most people assign zero percent
value
to there being any sort of structural uh
issue
and bitcoiner's assigned one percent
probability of there being a structural
issue that ends up being catastrophic
bitcoins are probably closer to the
truth than the people who assign zero
value right just
by the nature of it being a non-zero
probability and so i think that that
mispricing
leads a lot of bitcoiners to simply look
at it as that insurance
um and so when you start to extrapolate
this out to not this bitcoin community
but the
kind of global macro environment you now
have billionaires doing this you know
have fortune 500 companies doing
this you now have pension funds doing it
you have sovereign wealth funds doing it
there's a lot of people who are starting
to say wait a second i got zero exposure
and zero exposure's the wrong number
maybe i should have 25 basis points or
maybe i should have 25
but i got to have some exposure i can't
be on zero anymore so
so oh you know when it when something
like this is taking place
take a guy like warren buffett when you
think about investments you think about
a warren buffett right you
take a raid value you got to put them in
there right ray dalio what he's done
himself
you know buffett is talking about silver
hey he put his money in silver and right
now i think he's sitting on 200 billion
dollars of cash
is what he's sitting on imagine if that
200 billion dollars would have been in
portion
you know crypto 800 you're talking about
1.6 trillion dollars
is what uh uh uh berkshire hathaway
would have had
it would have been the largest company
in the world even bigger than amazon and
the other
if they just would have put their cash
in there but buffett
is not bought in ray dalio's critical
about it because he thinks regulation is
going to get to it
do you think what is happening is the
old-timers who have had their set of
philosophies
that's worked for them for decades
they are so set in stone with the way
they see what's worked for them that
they're not
willing to break from it to say hey
maybe we have to
take a look at what's going on with
crypto do you think
the next phase a lot of these old-school
heavy-duty
people that we've respected for decades
are gonna be
exposed not even exposed like they don't
know what they're doing obviously they
know what they're doing
but maybe their method of investment is
outdated for 2021
and these are people you and i admire
these are people that we have a lot of
respect for what do you think about that
yeah so i think it's important to call
it right out of the gate anyone who says
that warren buffett is
an idiot or ray dalio or you know name
your kind of favorite
uh kind of historic uh return investor
uh you know they're just being
intellectually dishonest so they had an
epic run they're absolutely some of the
best investors in the world
now with that said they made most of
their money
uh or the decisions they made that made
most of their money in a different world
right it wasn't a digital technology
driven world for the most part as we
know it today
and so when you look at you know a
warren buffett for example
uh he hasn't outperformed the s p for
the last decade
now again that doesn't take anything
away from his track record he's one of
the best investors in the world
but the world has either changed or he's
the rational person in an irrational
world
so you can take your pick as to why the
you know this is played out this way but
he hasn't beat the s p in the last
decade and so if you had taken his
approach
you've underperformed now there's plenty
of people who say well look at uh
somebody on the extreme other end
masayoshi sun from softbank right who i
don't think anyone thinks that masayoshi
and warren buffett sit down and they're
like we're gonna pick the same stocks
we're going to pick the same investment
strategy
right but masayoshi everyone thought it
was crazy and also it looks like
softbank's vision fund's going to do
pretty dang well
and so i think when you start to really
unpack some of this you've got to look
at okay what is the environment that
we're in
this technology-enabled kind of digital
world what are the investments
and what i think that we're starting to
unpack here is
uh there's a lot of hero worship that
happens in the financial markets right
it's because you did something
10 years ago or 20 years ago of course
you're going to be smart here
sometimes that is true but i think
that's a very dangerous precedent to
kind of fall under and so what i like to
do is just simply look at and say
okay what are you trying to accomplish
for a young guy like me
it's asymmetry right and so that
asymmetry ends up being really important
because you can risk less capital and
there's a higher payoff more risk but
higher payoff
and so if that's what you're looking for
it's actually the exact opposite thing
of what warren buffett is trying to
accomplish
right warren buffett understands he's
got 200 billion dollars in cash he's got
this big machine he wants to protect his
wealth he wants to continue to compound
it and if you can compound
you know uh hundreds of billions of
dollars at eight ten percent a year
you're going to do just fine
bitcoin has compounded a 200 percent
compound annual growth rate for a decade
so simply just holding bitcoin right
would have drastically outperformed
warren buffett
now that doesn't mean that either one of
those people are right or wrong it's
just they're optimizing for something
different
and so what i think will end up
happening is the older generation the
the folks who are kind of
um at the ends of their career they're
not going to come around right they just
a lot of them will even say that i'm not
a technology investor i don't understand
this stuff it violates a lot of my world
view
i just i'm a value person or whatever
their strategy is
what i do think is likely to happen
though is a lot of the younger people in
their organizations
as they rise up in kind of power
influence and positions
they'll start to diversify into a lot of
this so
there will be a day where berkshire
hathaway buys bitcoin it's probably not
going to be warren buffett pulling the
trigger on that decision
it'll probably be somebody else listen
foresight you know great uh
great uh prediction of what could
potentially happen but it's it's got to
be pretty tough to be done because
even the other day for example when i'm
asking about the biggest enemy that
crypto may have bitcoin may have right
um
janet yellen not a fan you know that
she's not a fan
powell not a fan uh ray dalio said
there's probably going to be regulation
coming to it i mean i can't give you a
list of names
plethora of names politically that are
not for what can happen to
crypto and bitcoin and all of that what
is the worst thing
you know because some people say if you
really understand bitcoin
you will know they can never regulate
bitcoin right you've hear you've heard
that saying before millions of times by
uh pro crypto folks but what
is the worst thing a yellen a
powell a biden the political people can
do
to the crypto world well i think they've
already probably done it and hasn't
stopped it right and so i'll give you
two scenarios uh one is an international
scenario where we have some data points
and then once what's happening in the
united states
so internationally we've seen people ban
it right we've seen pakistan
we've seen nigeria china we've seen
multiple countries go and ban it and
when they ban it guess what happens
adoption goes through the roof
right so actually by banning it you're
almost running a marketing campaign
and especially in those countries where
people already have a distrust for their
government the second the government
says don't do something they
ask why does the government not want me
to do that right and they actually go
and they adopt it yeah
um and so i think that banning it is a
great example of what not to do for a
government
if a government wants to quote unquote
attack bitcoin or be adversarial to
bitcoin the
better thing for them to do would
probably be overly regulatory right or
like have an overreach in the regulatory
realm
and so if you look at bitcoin bitcoin is
the most regulated currency in the
united states
and here's what i mean by that if you
and i go to dinner and you buy dinner
with dollars you simply pay sales tax on
that transaction
if i buy uh dinner with bitcoin i not
only have to pay the sales tax
i didn't have to pay capital gains short
or long term on the purchase
because it's treated as property for me
now cashing out to
uh to pay for this thing and so from a
regulatory standpoint there's actually a
financial incentive for me
not to use bitcoin in the united states
right that that is a
obstacle that even though it's in place
this year bitcoin's on chain transaction
volume meaning people actually using it
not for trading on exchanges but
actually using it for whatever purpose
will be over five trillion dollars of
on-chain transaction volume
that's more transaction volume this year
and last year then venmo apple pay or
paypal
so people who say no one's using it like
wait a second this is more about
congress
okay that jamie dimon said chase is
seven trillion so wait a minute
did you just say it's five trillion
dollars just for bitcoin
in the last 12 months if you take
uh the current on-chain transaction
volume you just annualize it right
it'll be over seven trillion dollars of
transaction volume on
the actual bitcoin blockchain this year
in 2020 seven or five
seven or five seven seven got it yes and
so when you start to unpack some of this
you really start to understand that okay
even though there is this big obstacle
around taxation
right people are still using it the
second thing is everyone forgets
you don't actually ever regulate an
asset right it's not like you're gonna
put the dollar in jail or you're gonna
go and get the dollar bill and scream at
it and say give me your tax money
so same thing with bitcoin right the
asset itself isn't what gets regulated
it's the organizations and the people
who use it transact support
and have related services to it and so
in the united states
a crypto company is subject to all of
the same rules and regulations as any
financial company
if you need to have a money transmitter
license in the regular finance world you
need to have it in crypto if you need a
broker dealer license kyc
aml all that stuff but in certain areas
let's say in the state of new york
if you're a crypto company you have to
get an additional license that the other
financial companies don't have to get
something called a bit license so it's
actually harder for you to conduct a
crypto business in the state of new york
than it is for you to conduct our
traditional
financial institution and so in some
crazy way
bitcoin and the crypto ecosystem is more
regulated than the traditional financial
system
and that kind of blows people's minds
because they're like what do you mean
how is this possible whatever
well if you tax it more than other
currencies and then you make the
companies get additional
licenses that other financial companies
don't need to get then what you're doing
is you're actually putting up these
obstacles
even though all of that's occurred you
have in the liquid market a two plus
trillion dollar market cap
bitcoin's a trillion dollar of that and
then on top of that you've got multiple
multi-billion dollar companies within
the united states have been built in
this industry
and so no matter what regulation you put
in the way even if in other countries
you ban it
or in the united states you simply try
to regulate it it doesn't matter
people have spoken this is superior
technology it's a better system they
want it and they're gonna use it
and just like they did to uber and
airbnb where they try to use regulation
and kind of all of this political
overreach it doesn't matter if people
want it they're going to get it and
that's
the new paradigm in the technology world
is the technology
is superior from an adoption standpoint
to any sort of regulation you can put
away you can disincentivize it all you
want
if it is better and it has product
market fit it will be adopted
uh anthony what uh what is easier for
law enforcement to investigate and find
fbi you know ftc pick them you know
scc any one of them pick any any one of
those guys
would they prefer cryptocurrency being
the
you know modern day day-to-day usage of
uh
uh uh you know currency that we use over
fiat or even gold
is it easier to trace the bad guy doing
what he's doing with crypto
so naturally uh bitcoin is a transparent
ledger
literally every single transaction is
put into a public ledger that you can go
on the internet and you could search
anyone in the world with an internet
connection can search this thing
uh so i always joke that a law
enforcement officer
uh who was in uh in one of the uh the
the federal law enforcement uh agencies
once told me if a criminal is committing
a crime we want their hands on a
keyboard
right it leaves a digital trail and so
it's always easier for them to track it
that's not just currency that's just any
crime in general we want their hands on
a keyboard
uh with that said the choice currency of
money launders
drug dealers criminals terrorists etc
around the world today is absolutely us
dollars
there's estimations that come out of the
uk uh in some of their
uh kind of national uh studies that over
two trillion dollars
is laundered annually annually two
trillion dollars is laundered
in the fiat system with us dollars well
that's the entire size of
all cryptocurrencies combined so you
start looking at this you say okay well
what about on a percentage basis
well there's estimations that anywhere
between one to three percent of all us
dollar
uh transactions are used for illicit
purposes uh globally
the latest estimation when it comes to
cryptocurrency is 0.4
40 basis points that's all is the
illicit transactions
you just had a former cia director come
out and say listen this whole
kind of narrative that a lot of people
in government and in the central bank
and treasury
are spinning around that's used for
illicit purposes he's like it's not true
the data does not support that
and the beauty is that we can actually
prove it because it's all
on chain and so there's this very
interesting conversation around yes law
enforcement has a much better ability to
kind of track this stuff and analyze it
but it's also important to keep
the privacy the financial privacy the
human right to be able to use money
without being tracked by your government
at the same time
and so i think that's the conversation
that's going to start coming up here
over the next couple of years
you know the great answer they're very
helpful medical
i asked them i said how come you don't
live in us why do you live in singapore
right and if you go look at the
economic index on heritage's website the
highest one today is singapore
i think they just passed new zealand
they're number one right now meaning the
freest country in the world you can live
in
you're living in u.s i said why aren't
you living in us he says i lived in
canada i lived in uk i lived in india
and i live in now singapore
he said i wouldn't want to live in the
u.s because u.s has fingerprints they
want to know everything you have over
here i don't pay capital gains i don't
pay this i don't pay that the income
taxes
10 or 20 percent and i don't have all
these other taxes on top of it and they
don't
know how much money i have how
optimistic are you on the future of uh
america you talked about america earlier
where you said americans have a tendency
of believing that's going to be the
greatest country in the world and you
know
currency no one can go up against the
currencies the best currency in the
world how optimistic
are you with america as a product not
not crypto not bitcoin
yeah so i believe that america and the
american ideals are
cr have created and still is the
greatest country in the world right
and the belief in capitalism free
markets and democracy
uh we are very spoiled here in this
country
uh compared to where most people live uh
in the world
uh with that said uh i always look at it
as
just because you were able to ascend to
this position of
uh of privilege and power and and kind
of freedom
does not mean that is guaranteed in the
future and so in the united states i
think that what we are starting to get
to a point of is
we're the fat cat in the room right
we're happy
this is america we can do no wrong we've
got the greatest military in the world
we've got a global reserve currency
we are the kings of the world well
every dynasty and empire in history has
fallen
and usually it is because they become
the fat cat in the room they stop
pursuing innovation they stop pursuing
kind of independent thought and problem
solving and critical thinking
and they simply start saying we win
because we are america
right and i think it's a very dangerous
place to be in and so i think that the
the best place frankly that this is
showing up
is in something like bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies where when you look at
an
open decentralized system you can see
the rhetoric that's being used in a lot
of this people are starting to say
oh some one of our adversaries may use
this technology
and that will be detrimental to the
united states well when you're the
incumbent
you constantly look at regulation and
you look at how can i rig the market to
my advantage how do i king make right
when you're the startup that's not what
you think you think give me the tools
and i'll compete in the free market
you you enjoy the competition right you
want to go fight the battle
and so i think that what we've got to do
is we've got to get back to that right
the industrial revolution and a lot of
what made america america
was about us saying give us the
technology and we're going to go compete
in a free market and we're going to win
and so i think that what ends up
happening is we've got a decision to
make
we're we are the greatest country in the
world do we want to continue to do that
or are we going to go into decline
and i think that what we have to do is
we have to continue to pursue
technological innovation
and we have to uh make sure that through
incentives whether that's tax
regulation or otherwise that we want the
smartest people in the world
living here working here building here
and employing people
and if we do that we got a shot no
guarantee
but we got a shot but i think there's a
couple of other countries that are
starting to catch on to the game
right singapore uh is one area there's
plenty of others
that start saying look we're gonna take
the american playbook and we're gonna
use it against them
so let's go compete yeah it's gonna be
interesting and by the way china
right now i don't know if you saw what
came out story this week when they said
china looks at us as their equal they no
longer look at their superior this was
said this monday
we talked about on the podcast and you
heard peter thiel i think last week i
think it was last week when he talked
about the fact that hey
you know china's using bitcoin as a way
to
manipulate the us currency the fiat
currency this is the national security
so what do you think about what peter
thiel is saying because you you when you
talk about the startup hey just 20 years
ago china was number eight
you know china was number seven and they
did that the olympics and oh wait i
think it was when we're like what the
hell would
the way they would walk how many times
are these guys there's a greatest
opening show ever like these guys are
going to compete they went from eight
seven six five
four three two in 2025 they're planning
on being number one
what do you think peter thiel is saying
the fact that they're gonna use
bitcoin to manipulate the u.s currency
to weaken it yeah so i think that
uh the context of his comments are
really important right so first
is uh he was very clear that he's pro
bitcoin he's pro crypto he considers
himself a bitcoin maximalist
uh and uh and believes that it will
continue to accrue value as this like
global store of value
the second thing is that right before he
talked about bitcoin he actually said
that
uh at one point the euro was seen as a
financial weapon by china against the
united states
and it ended up not actually being able
to uh kind of weaken the dollar enough
or have the impact that they wanted it
to have right so this is not a new
concept or a new framework for people to
kind of evaluate
china's global aspirations compared to
the us uh and so the idea with bitcoin
is that
uh if people start to adopt bitcoin then
that will destabilize the global
uh reserve currency right and and
bitcoin will end up being uh kind of
global reserve currency
now what i always say is bitcoin is a
open network it's an open decentralized
network very similar to the internet
and so when the internet came along the
united states had a very big hand in
creating that and adopting it
embracing it using it to their advantage
but there are countries around the world
that said oh my god other people are
going to use this
and so we're not going to use it we're
going to cut our citizens off from the
internet north korea is a great example
it didn't turn out so hot for north
korea and their citizens and so when you
have an open decentralized network
naturally people around the world are
going to use it open systems
beat closed systems and so when you
think of it from that standpoint
the united states has a choice we can be
adversarial
and we can be kind of closed
system-minded right we can say hey we're
not going to use this thing because
another country may try to
adopt it or use it and use it to their
benefit
or we can simply say you know what
there's a global game
we're going to go compete we're going to
embrace this and we're going to make
sure that if anyone benefits from
bitcoin in this open system
we benefit more than anybody else and i
think that's the winning strategy here
is it's not to say
oh let's ban our our citizens from using
this let's try to look at this as a
threat
it's to say hey there's a weapon up for
grab let's go use it and we'll be the
winners
because every other country is going to
do that as well so why don't you just go
make sure you benefit more than
everybody else from it
it's interesting open systems with
closed systems i mean
some would say obviously you know the
whole made in china 2025 they've been
taking all our
you know secret you know everything
trade secrets that we have when they're
doing business with companies we get to
use their trade secrets in china they
use it
some would say china's closed
and u.s has been open and how is china
being closed and they're catching up to
us so
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens there with that but let me let
me go to a completely different side now
we've covered a lot of things with
bitcoin
you know maybe one prediction so the
audience can see this at sixty one
thousand four fourteen as of right now
uh you predicted it's gonna get to what
a hundred thousand by the end of the
year some people are saying two or three
times higher than you by the end of the
year
and you predicted 2026 bitcoin's gonna
get to a million
and the way you described it is because
an event that's going to take place in
do you mind unpacking that and
explaining what you mean
to say bitcoin's going to get to a
million by 2026.
yeah so uh it's all goes to the
programmatic monetary policy
right so when you look at bitcoin from a
structural standpoint 21 million bitcoin
will ever be created the way that that
enters into the circulating supply
is back in 2009 50 bitcoin
every 10 minutes was put into the
circulating supply via something called
a bitcoin reward that we could talk
about later
uh and so that happened every 10 minutes
50 bitcoiner put into circulating supply
for four years
after four years there was a supply
shock
where that 50 bitcoin every 10 minutes
went to 25 bitcoin every 10 minutes
so it was written into code people knew
it was happening but it went
got cut in half right it's called the
bitcoin having when that event occurs
and you have a supply shock
if demand continues to grow at the same
rate you naturally will get a repricing
of an asset
right supply goes down on a daily basis
but demand stays constant or goes up
the price has to move up to accommodate
the change in the supply schedule
so 50 to 25 25 for four years and then
got cut in half again to 12 and a half
did that for four years in may of 2020
it ended up getting cut in half again
uh as it was scheduled to uh to 6.25
and so back in 2019 i said look when
this having occurs
there's going to be a repricing of the
asset right the supply
shock is going to drive the price higher
and so 100k what was the number
now the reason why i say a million
dollars by 2026
is that in 2024 there is going to be
another supply shock there will be
another cutting in half from 6.25
right 50 reduction and so naturally what
just happens
is when those supply shocks occur
there's a re-pricing by the market of
the asset
now what's really fascinating about this
if anyone studies kind of financial
markets or looks at financial assets
is that in the traditional world there's
uh commodities like let's say gold that
use stock to flow
analysis stock to flow simply says how
many gold how much gold is in the world
and then how much is coming in on a
daily weekly or monthly basis and you
try to predict both the supply side of
the equation
and the demand side and therefore gives
you future price predictions
well with bitcoin you know with 100
certainty the supply side of the
schedule so i know
exactly how many bitcoin there are today
and i can tell you on each day into the
future with near 100
accuracy how many bitcoin there are
going to be so when you can model out
with
accuracy the supply side and it's
programmatic you only have to focus on
predicting
the demand side right because i know
with certainty in the in the
programmatic monetary policy supply
so now it just comes down to demand and
so what you can do is you can basically
just extrapolate out we've got 12 years
of data well what's the growth rate of
people coming into bitcoin
and you just continue to extrapolate
that out and what you start to realize
is
this stock to flow analysis is deadly
accurate
right and so naturally when you see that
sure
are there days where bitcoin trades
above or below where it's supposed to be
of course right it's a volatile asset
uh in some ways but at the same time the
direction of this thing is very very
accurate because
50 of the supply demand equation is no
and so in in this crazy crazy world
bitcoin is actually a
more predictable asset than almost any
other asset in the world
because it's fully transparent so so
at the way you described it you said
gold is
what 10 trillion you said 10 trillion
right now bitcoin is a trillion
uh and the uh this is potentially going
to end up being twice as big as gold
uh because with gold you know you can't
really track with this it's more
trackable
it's easier so 20 trillion dollar market
the 20 trillion dollar you know that
breaks down to be a million dollars
per bitcoin do you think it has a
possibility in 2031 to get to 5 million
do you think it has a possibility by
2040 to get to 10 million
or do you think it's gonna get to a
point and kind of level off and stay
there for a while
so let's remove uh the time scale from
the conversation for a second right
so to have an accurate prediction you
need to have an event and you need to
have a time
right but let's take away time for a
second and just talk about directional
progress
uh the reason why some of these
industries are so big right around
stores of value
art real estate right etc a lot of
commodity markets
is because the dollar is devalued right
if the dollar wasn't devalued if you
could simply
get paid in dollars leave it in your
bank account and have the same
or more more purchasing power in the
future you would never get out of the
dollar you would simply save right if
you go to like let's say a country like
india
uh where the culture was you basically
got gold
and then you just passed the gold dom
from generation to generation to
generation
right well in the u.s and in many
developed countries you can't do that
because the currency is being devalued
so you're financially incentivized to
either consume
goods and services or to invest the
capital right and that's part of the
velocity of money and all this kind of
stuff
so that is a feature of the system not a
bug
when all of a sudden you can simply save
in
an asset a currency like bitcoin you can
get paid in bitcoin and simply leave it
there
people will stop or drastically slow
down the rate of
investment into other store value assets
that's why you see gold going down and
people simply saving a bitcoin
uh you can look at uh high-end art you
can look at real estate in the future
and so in a crazy way i personally
believe
uh without a time uh prediction on it
that one day bitcoin will be a
hundred trillion dollar asset right it's
100x from here
now does that take yeah does that take
uh one year does that take 20 years 50
years i don't know right i don't want to
get into kind of the time component
because that's the hardest part of that
prediction
but what i do know is that it's not
crazy to think that if bitcoin is a
let's say 100 or 1000x improvement on
the technology front
than gold that naturally if you just are
a 10x better
or a bigger market cap than gold then
you would be 100 trillion
right because gold's 10 trillion times
10 is just 100 trillion
and so the other part of this that
becomes really crazy is
we're talking about in 2026 being 2x the
current gold market cap
right today we're sitting at a trillion
dollar bitcoin uh market cap to get to
uh 20 trillion 20x 2x the gold market
cap
well the conversation that no one's
happening is when does the flipping
happen between bitcoin and gold
it's not when bitcoin gets to 10
trillion because by the time bitcoin
continues to grow
gold's market cap is going to continue
to contract
and if you look at the actual
distribution of ownership
in gold everyone always likes to point
and say
uh oh well you use gold in your cell
phone and you know all this technology
and stuff
seven percent of gold usage or ownership
is due to any sort of technology
application the majority of it is in
store of value and jewelry jewelry
demand for b
for gold peaked in 2013 and has been on
the steady decline since
the store of value we just saw central
banks in q4 were net sellers of gold
gold's market cap is going to continue
to contract as the world gets digitized
and people literally drop gold and shift
capital into a digital store of value
and so my guess is that the kind of
flipping of gold and bitcoins market cap
is not going to happen at the 10
trillion
maybe it's at nine or eight and a half
trillion and so you start looking at
this very crazy world and you start
saying wait a second
these are not static numbers right
gold's market cap eventually may be 2
trillion
just because people dump gold and they
start moving into other assets
yeah so let me ask you so my other
thought goes to a place where
a jamie dimon a
warren buffett a dalio take any of these
guys that
already have a lot of power and
influence they sit there and say
why would i use bitcoin why don't i come
up with my own you know cryptocurrency
that uh a uh uh chase is gonna use i
have power what about if i bring the
smartest guys and they start mining they
start doing the same exact 50 25 12 and
a half six and a quarter
three and an eight and then boom you go
all the way down let's do the same thing
let's put the same kind of timeline
together
if the formula worked and singapore is
using us's uh approach
because it worked why don't we use what
worked with bitcoin but let's control it
here within b of a let's control it here
with chase
let's control here with goldman or
morgan whoever it is so if
binance is the direct competitor to
coinbase
who would essentially be the direct
competitor to bitcoin
there there is no competitor to bitcoin
right because bitcoin has the
only thing that actually matters in this
entire game
in order to have a non-state currency
you need full decentralization
if you do not have decentralization you
will fail and the reason why i say that
is because the government has a monopoly
on violence and so if you are jamie
dimon and you want to create your own
currency
which they thought about doing or your
facebook and you want to create your own
currency
which they did right what happens
immediately the government says mark
zuckerberg come in talk to congress
you're not allowed to do this we're
going to make all these changes right
and and this is a no go
there is no ceo to call in from bitcoin
there's no way to shut it down
decentralization is the security
so the framework i use for this is to
ascend to a global reserve currency
throughout history there was violent
combat one country or one
you know a kind of geographic location
or kingdom
went engaged in combat prevailed
and then installed their currency as the
global reserve currency
but in a digital world the most powerful
military
is not the one that is best offensively
it is the one that is best defensively
so in the analog world whoever's got the
more bombs bullets guns soldiers etc you
have the most military might therefore
you get the global reserve currency the
united states is dominating
in that fashion over the last couple of
centuries or decades
in the cyber world if you can simply
just keep everyone
out from hacking you then you're the
most powerful
and bitcoin is the strongest computing
network in the world there's no computer
or computer network in the world
stronger than bitcoin it has the best
cyber defense
it is protecting a trillion plus dollar
asset and no one can hack it i don't
care what
government you are what individual what
corporation organization et cetera you
cannot hack bitcoin
because it is so decentralized and has
so much computing power running it
so when you get to that world what ends
up happening is it doesn't matter what
any government says
it doesn't matter what any politician
says they can try to regulate
individuals or corporations
but they cannot shut down the network
and that open decentralized network
naturally value will flow there and so
if jamie dimon wants to start his own
coin
that's a great idea for him to try but
he'll never be successful in getting
global adoption
because he's always going to have to
answer to a government that says
jamie right you are not allowed to do
this because now you are a direct
competition to our nation-state currency
well let me ask you a question doesn't
doesn't that kind of make you
the buffet of the world that's too cocky
to think that somebody else can't come
and take you guys like
you know what i'm saying does not kind
of make you make make it be like america
where you become you know complacent and
too confident to think that somebody
else can come and take you out that's my
only thing where i think
it's worked so effectively that
someone's going to say we're going to do
it ourselves and we have a name already
where there's certain competition so you
have to remember that
uh there is a hyper villagent uh uh
in the bitcoin community right and what
i mean by that is
every single day millions of people
around the world
are running the numbers they're
constantly looking at
is the code executing correctly is there
anyone who's trying to do anything
nefarious or malicious
has anybody gotten too much uh computing
power or hashrate on the network like
like this hyper diligence around this
transparent asset
we're talking about an asset that had no
venture funding or any sort of you know
equity capital contributed
it had no team no ceo no founder no
marketing team no partnerships team no
anything and it got all of these people
around the world
to build it run it protect it etc and
it's grown into a trillion dollar asset
and it's all because incentives run the
world and a decentralized open system is
superior to every other system in the
world
so here's what here's my greatest fear
as jamie dimon and other people start
going into this world
right i've called it the uh the
corporate central uh
bank playbook and i've been writing
about this for a while uh but i think
it's a world where we're gonna be
very very scared if we answer this jp
morgan said that they were gonna create
jpm coin a while ago
and jpm coin was going to be backed one
to one to the us dollar
so they put a bunch of dollars in a bank
account right and they would issue a
digital dollar or jpm coin
and then you would go around you could
use this thing uh and they would start
with their corporate
customers right their partners then
eventually they would push it out to
retail they get merchants using it et
cetera
but then just like the us dollar was
d-pegged from gold
jamie dimon and jp morgan in the future
can just say you know what we're not
going to unpeg it from the dollar
and now all of a sudden jp morgan is in
charge and controls
a currency that has you know global or
national adoption
but they are the central bank they can
print as much as they want contract the
supply as they want etc
and so i've been a very big proponent
that they're they're
i'm usually not a very big proponent of
regulation but
there needs to be a conversation
immediately that
if a financial institution goes ahead
and says
we are going to create a digital
currency and it is backed by a basket of
currencies commodities whatever
that is okay but you are not allowed to
change it in the future
so if you tell people it's back one to
one to the dollar and then you want to
unpeg it in the future
now what we're doing is we're really
threatening the national currencies
because we're going to give corporations
the ability to be central banks
right that's a world i don't think we
want to go into and so when you compare
would you rather a decentralized
transparent monetary uh system
or would you rather jp morgan control
the currency yeah because then it goes
back to the old school of doing business
where one person so powerful that you're
scared of them because they can make any
decision that that makes a lot of sense
so
by the way i'm a math guy you sound like
a math guy right you know when you were
back in school and you had this one
tough formula teacher will write it on
the board you're like
holy how and then you would sit there
your brain is just going crazy because
you're trying to really figure this
thing out
who the hell is this person that figured
out the math for
bitcoin the 50 25 12 and a half the
timing every four years
mining how does one even
i mean you know i've interviewed craig
right before oh i am satoshi and you
know when i did that i you have no idea
how many hate let me
email people you can i cannot believe
you even had the audacity to have them
on
everyone knows he's not satoshi all this
other person what do you think about
when you think about the person forget
about asking who do you think it is i'm
not asking who do you think it is
what do you think about what it takes
for a person to create
something like this from scratch where a
trillion dollar
asset today what do you think about the
brain it takes to create something like
this
yeah um there's two key components here
in my opinion
one is uh there's a beauty in this like
immaculate conception story right nobody
knows who the founder is the
pseudonymity
uh the way it was introduced all that
stuff is actually a key feature of
bitcoin
i don't want to know who it is and i
don't think that it would be necessarily
good for bitcoin if people knew
i don't think it would be fatal either
but i think that having this like
nameless or
or faceless founder is actually a really
strong thing because there's nobody to
point at or to talk to or call in front
of congress all that kind of stuff so i
think that's kind of the first piece is
the satoshi nakamoto uh almost like
legend
is a key component very important the
second thing is
people don't understand that this is
actually not the first iteration
of a attempt at a global digital
currency
right there was bitgold and a couple of
other attempts previously
and they didn't get it right there was
either problems with this double spend
problem
or other types of issues that popped up
and so whoever the individual
or group of people who came up with
bitcoin they actually had some kind of
shoulders to stand on right there was
previous attempts and
people were able to kind of see okay
somebody tried this type of iteration it
didn't work
well we can figure out a solution to
that and so obviously whoever
did this whether it's an individual or a
group incredibly intelligent i mean the
design of bitcoin is beautiful
both from kind of the monetary policy
we've been talking about
the uh difficulty uh adjustments that
occur in the mining system
etc but i also think that uh
in some crazy crazy world it takes
humility it takes a humbleness whoever
the individual is or the group
to have created something and to not say
anything to not go move
the you know whatever is 800 000 a
million bitcoin or whatever that's in
the satoshi wallets
that's a lot of money and so when you
start to look at this system
this is a special person or group to not
only have been smart enough to design it
to not only have been smart enough to
introduce it into the system
to also disappear right and to kind of
walk away
but then also not to financially benefit
from it it's pretty incredible when you
start to kind of unpack a lot of this
and i think that uh over the years
satoshi nakamoto will probably end up
being seen as one of the most important
people or groups in the world
and the beauty is we just don't know who
it is yeah it's it's really
really interesting when you think about
that because even you know he may
essentially be the richest man in the
world today if you think about it if you
just do the math he's probably the
richest man in the world today
what if he's dead what if she's dead
what if he's not around what if no one's
ever going to tap into that key
where is that money going to sit how is
that going to be controlled are they
going to try to figure out a way to make
it loose so other people can touch
touch it i don't know it's very
interesting when you think about that a
couple couple other conversations
uh three topics that were done here what
do you think about collectibles what do
you think about cards you know cards
you're seeing a million dollars half a
million dollars 65 million dollars what
do you think about the growth of cards
where
a lot of the younger generation that's
also turned on by crypto
by nft is also starting to be turned on
by collectible cards
look uh a lot of this is macro related i
think just in the sense of there's so
much quantitative easing there's so much
devaluation of currencies
uh people are looking around the room
and they're saying what's going on i got
to get out of the dollar i say they want
to go buy stuff now
i don't know what percentage of people
are buying cards or bitcoin or
name your asset uh because of that but
there's definitely some element
of uh they're running from something the
second thing is they all got a ton of
money savings rates up personal income's
up right there's just money sloshing
around the system and so we got extra
cash
uh there's people who just want to go
invest and buy things and make more
money
and kind of do all of that uh the third
thing is uh for
a long period of time last year there
was no sports there's no entertainment
and so naturally you know if you were
betting on games or doing whatever
well what's the next best thing i'm
gonna go bet in the stock market it's
you know basically the same thing i'm
just trying to make money
that there's an entertainment factor uh
and then the last thing i think
is uh kind of this gamification or or an
access play
right if all of a sudden now on my
computer screen
i can do this easily uh and i can get a
dopamine hit from it
what's the difference between me trying
to buy a card on ebay turn around and
flip it a week later
versus me scrolling mindlessly on
instagram or twitter it's all dope of me
yeah right and so i think that just
naturally like you're seeing this
again generational shift these digital
natives that are kind of starting to do
this
uh i think that whether we're talking
about nfts uh
you're talking about nba top shot you're
talking about the actual physical cards
uh i think that you're gonna get these
boom and bust cycles right so like
if you zoom out you say hey 25 years
from now is this asset class gonna be
bigger or smaller than it is today
definitely bigger in my mind if you say
to me okay now draw out the boom and
bust cycles between now and then i got
no clue
right like it's just naturally you're
gonna get some frothy times you're going
to get some drawdowns
and so i think people just got to
understand are you actually speculating
and trying to like day trade whether
it's cards collectibles nfts whatever
or are you a long-term holder of this
and you're going to buy it and never
sell it
and if you just know who you are just
understand the risk you're taking the
pros and cons of that strategy and knock
yourself out
we're on the same page there two last
topics one
let's talk about trump and let me
explain to where i'm going with trump
i'm not asking you about your political
beliefs or anything like that
say you are on uh
trump's advisory board okay
hypothetically not saying you are i
don't know where you live politically
but let's just say you're sitting on
trump's advisory board
he's been silenced now for what six
months twitter suspended him and then
everybody else followed suit no one's
opened it up
he did an interview with his daughter uh
daughter-in-law laura trump was put on
facebook taken out within 24 hours so
it's not just
him trying to speak him speaking on
other platforms is also being taken down
right last uh four weeks people have
been calling me telling me pat check out
bitcloud bitcloud bitcoin
shamath behind it then andrew and you
know all these people are behind us they
took the top 15 000 accounts on twitter
and they put it on there and they're
waiting and
20 when they come and they're collecting
all this other stuff and then
so i posed a question on twitter and i
said hey bitcloud
uh uh if uh twitter and bitcoin had a
baby it would be bitcloud
thoughts what are you doing with this
scam are you kidding me you have bought
into this there's no way in the world
you individually can invest into
somebody
but the idea is very interesting then i
got about a hundred people that
commented that it's about twitch
not twitch but twitch t-w-e-t-c-h
dot app i believe twitch right i'm gonna
put the link below if people want to
find out more about
either one of them so bit bit clout and
so why why would you want to get on
bitcoin
because it's decentralized so if anybody
wants to tweet you cannot get suspended
you cannot do this you can
not do that do you think the future of
social media
to give back the freedom of speech where
somebody cannot ban you will also be
linked to a
blockchain cryptocurrency decentralized
type of a platform where the individual
can have the freedom to
say whatever they want to say do you see
social media going in that direction
one of my core uh investment thesis is
that decentralized products are going to
be much larger than centralized products
right so a decentralized twitter if done
correctly will be much bigger than
twitter
uh decentralized exchanges on the stock
market or cryptocurrency markets would
be much bigger than centralized ones
and then the second thing is that as
part of that theme
uh the users of these platforms will
have to have a financial stake
regardless of what the actual mechanism
is in order for
them to be successful in the future so
kind of decentralization is key
and then having uh less of a middleman
or kind of a rent seeker
and more of a flow through of the
financials to the participants in an
ecosystem
or community so with that as the
backdrop uh i don't know if bitcloud is
the answer
or some variation that somebody else
comes up with but i
absolutely believe that there is going
to be somebody who cracks this idea of
uh decentralization both from a kind of
a security freedom of speech all that
stuff
and also a financial incentive how do
you bootstrap a network how do you
actually create an economy um yeah
what's the difference let's say between
big clout and uh these decentralized
kind of creator coins
um versus maybe clubhouse and the
ability to pay the creators directly in
clubhouse
sure there's centralization
decentralization once digital currencies
one's kind of more traditional fiat
currencies whatever
but from a structural standpoint the
idea still is like the audience and the
participants
have an exchange of value one is i'm
providing you a service right or kind of
goods
you're providing me currency and so i
think that what we're starting to see is
people are playing around with it
they're experimenting they're trying to
innovate
i don't yet know what the solution is
and i think that's part of the fun of
all of this is trying to figure out who
cracks it
but i do think that the legacy models
that we've seen
will be archaic compared to where we end
up you know in the coming years
yeah i think so as well i think that's
the direction now you worked on voter
registration with facebook
do you also see this going under because
you know voting was a big problematic
issue this last time where people some
people didn't trust us some people are
like well it's this
even in 2016 there was voter fraud 2020
vote every election we have
one side that says there was voter fraud
to the other side right
do you think in order to have 100 trust
in how votes are also taking place it
would also be an
open decentralized maybe not the fact
that showing which side you voted on
because that's private for the
individual
do you think we can also use the same
technology to go in the direction to
make
voting a little bit more accurate with
people on both sides trusted more
yeah so i i come from a a position of um
every extreme in politics is idiotic
right like i'm much more of somebody
who's just like hey there's like common
sense and
it's probably truth in between all of
these things um but but the one thing
that uh when it comes to the voting
uh issues that uh just blows my mind is
i said to people listen
for decades now we have had people with
sometimes pencils right literally
filling out pieces of paper and we've
got millions and millions tens of
millions
if not hundreds of millions of people
all voting uh are you telling me that
you think there's been 100 accuracy
and i don't care what side benefited
didn't benefit whatever of course not
right and sometimes there's been really
egregious stuff and sometimes there's
literally just been
mistakes right you can't tell or the
chat or
whatever all this crazy stuff is that's
a narrative driven system
the narrative has been it's a free fair
accurate election
right the narrative has been that uh 100
of the vote
uh happens and there's no issues there's
no anything as we shift from that
narrative-based world
to a world where it comes more to uh the
validity and the verifiability and the
prove it to me
type narrative especially from the
younger people we naturally are going to
have to use technology to service that
need or that desire
what the system is i don't know yet how
you do it in terms of like you said uh
hey you voted but i don't want to see
what actually you voted but i want to
make sure that it counted in the right
bucket like
there's people way smarter than me that
will figure all of that out but i
actually think what becomes so crazy and
interesting about this
whether it's in financial markets or in
what is essentially a political market
is it creates a more fair and actual
accurate market right so if all of a
sudden we could guarantee that
everyone's vote actually counted the way
they wanted to
i think most people would agree like
that's a good thing and i'm not saying
that that didn't happen or it did happen
or whatever
but it's just like i think technology is
now getting to the point where people
are going to start demanding
hey i don't want to live in a narrative
driven world i want to live in a world
where i can verify what's being told to
me
whether it's from the media whether it's
from ceos of corporations
whether it's from governments or from
these decentralized platforms
i believe nobody has the default until
you prove it to me and i think that you
know
politics is no uh no different than any
other market anthony we all have
strengths what do you think yours is
i'm about to give you what i think what
what i forced the one of your biggest
strengths but i'm curious to know what
you think what you've been told
i think that uh at a very high level uh
i literally
just enjoy being myself and so
uh i'm just authentic like what you see
is what you get if you meet me on the
street if you go to dinner with me
or we sit here and talk like this is who
i am this is stuff i talk about
uh i don't really believe that you can
live in today's society with like a
uh a public persona or anything like
that it's just
people really really value the
authenticity and it makes it much easier
right it's just just be yourself and so
i think that i'm willing to do that i do
that and
uh that tends to be a really big
strength especially in a digital age
you're an absolute stud of a guy that's
going places we're gonna have to see you
and hear you for decades and decades and
decades
to come the way it's going you're pretty
much going to be in the billionaire
category and you know it that smile
tells the whole story behind that but
outside of that
i think one of your strengths is you're
an incredible teacher
you're very good at explaining topics in
a way
where i learned today just listening to
you
the way you break things down it's a
very unique gift of yours that you have
that i hope the audience enjoyed this
interview as much as i enjoyed it folks
if you want to hear more from
anthony he's got a podcast uh uh called
the pomp
podcast we're going to put the link
below we'll also put his twitter account
if you want to go message him
on what you took away from today's
interview anthony thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment listen
thank you so much for having me and i
appreciate the kind words but i've
learned a ton from you as well so uh
please keep it up because uh the rest of
us are enjoying all these interviews
you're doing
thank you thank you so much i rarely say
this this is probably the best interview
i've ever done on the topic of
cryptocurrency and bitcoin
uh anthony is an incredible teacher you
saw me say it right in front of him
kirsten know what you took away from it
comment below also if you enjoyed this i
have two interviews for you
we mentioned ray dalio if you've never
watched the interview with ray dahlia
click over here
and if you've not watched the video i
did with medicove and it's another one
both of these interviews
meadowcoven is the gentleman that's a
crypto billionaire who bought bpos every
day's for 69.3 million
if you've not watched that click over
here thanks for watching everybody take
care bye
[Music]